[Music]
[Applause]
Brady Quinn Fox college football analyst
big noon kickoff host of two pros and a
cup of joe former Notre Dame quarterback
joining us on the program good morning
Brady let's start with uh the obvious
How does each team win tonight here in
the national title
game uh it's a tough question answer
because I think a lot of people
have doubted this Washington Huskies
team and their ability to continue to
not only beat top ranked teams I me you
just go back to the Pack 12 championship
game look at the line of that game but I
think Michael penick's play and just
since he has arrived in Seattle for the
Huskies the way he has played the
ridiculous accuracy down the field throw
after throw and I know they've got a lot
of T talented wide receivers but he's
putting the ball in spots where only
those guys can get in the defense can't
and I think people keep waiting for it
to run out or for it to stop or maybe
for them to have a game that looks
similar to the Arizona State game where
they they got held out of the End Zone
it was all field goals but I don't know
that's gonna happen I kind of get those
like Joe burrow vibes from the LSU
season um where they just were
Unstoppable offensively and the defense
was good enough and maybe that's all
Washington has to be but the one thing
you can't measure Dan and this is where
I kind of got fooled too in and in
looking at that Bama Michigan matchup is
just the physic ality that Michigan
plays with and the tone they set early
on in games have the big plays you can
have the change of momentum you can have
anything you want but it still comes
down to the trenches and Michigan tries
to establish that right out the gate in
every game they play and they've been
really successful doing so and so that's
kind of one of those deals you can't
measure and just the fact that like
Michigan's now a change up in college
football you heard Nick Sav talk about
the challenge of going against a team
that huddles where you might know their
personnel grouping but you don't know
their formation and and you really have
to make a call and then stick with that
call because you don't have the ability
to change as compared to when you go
against a no huddle group that's at the
line of scrimmage and you can make a
change of call when they make a change
of call or they do something sometimes
there's time to do that you don't have
that versus Michigan offensively and
just the last thing is the Personnel
groupings not many people run out there
with two tight end three tight end two
running back two tight end sets and just
want to pound away with the football and
then build in some pass plays and things
off of that and I think it's tough to
prepare for because most college rosters
aren't built that way and Michigan's
unique in that sense so I think this is
one in where something's got to give and
and I don't think it's going to be
Michigan it just feels like this is that
year where Michigan finds a way of
winning a tight close game but it should
be a ton of fun to watch Harbaugh's
future do you think it hinges on the
outcome of this game
tonight I think if he wins you would
have to think that he's more to go and
take an opportunity and he's probably
got no short list of suitors I mean who
wouldn't want a guy that continually
builds teams at the college and NFL
level to be contenders and to be teams
that can win a championship that that's
what he's done and he's just got that
unique quality about him and really that
CEO quality where I feel like he's able
to make it work in both college and the
NFL I mean he's proven that already but
even the way he's built up this Michigan
program and and being able to build it
up this season without him even being
there I mean obviously he was a part of
the preparations throughout the course
of the week but on on six different
occasions he wasn't there he he wasn't
the head coach on the sidelines helping
his staff make those situational play
calls and and doing all of that and I
think that speaks volumes to how he's
able to build a program like Michigan to
withstand that sort of adversity even
without him let's look at these two
quarterbacks Pro uh Pro potential here
uh with JJ McCarthy and Michael penx Jr
let me start with penx
JR what do you think to me he he's got
the best tape of anyone this year in
college football I mean I understand
people and myself included are enamored
with Caleb Williams that the different
things he can do to to throw off
platform and the way he can run around
and buy time and create but there is no
one who reminds me more of CJ Stout in
regards to the downfield pinpoint
accuracy with the Deep ball and you're
seeing how that's playing out for
Houston now as they win the AFC South
and move on to the playoffs that is
Michael penx I mean he's proven that now
two years in a row and one standout year
at Indiana of all places with the
ability to do that now he's had a bunch
of injuries but like that's for a
medical doctor to decide I look at all
the injuries and say look at what this
young man has overcome and been able to
still play at this high of a level and I
think the last thing I'll say is he's a
he's a better athlete people give him
credit I think because of the injuries
he's had to adapt a bit to play more
from the pocket and he does that well
but his movement to throw in the pocket
his movement with pressure in his face
and able to get some of these throws off
and on point on the money is ridiculous
so I I would say this if you were only
basing this season in your draft
evaluation off of this year's film it'd
be Michael penx as the first quarterback
he he's been that special it's been that
ridiculous of a season for him I know
he's got a lot of other Talent around
him the wide receiver I I know he's got
Joe Mo award-winning offensive line and
Ryan grub and kayin D'Or are great play
callers it doesn't take away from how
he's executing the things he's done this
year all right JJ
McCarthy I I think he's the guy that
like he leaves you always wanting more
and that that's not an indictment on him
it's an indictment on kind of just the
way they play you know their system and
I think there could be an argument made
too that because they don't allow him to
throw the football 40 plus 50 plus times
a game it actually is more pressure on
him like he's got to deliver when they
go into that run run pass on third down
mode when you're in third and seven plus
or hey we've basically been hammering
away running the football JJ we now need
you to lead us on a two-minute drive and
you've only thrown I don't know 10 pass
attempts 12 pass attempts like it's hard
to get into a rhythm as a quarterback
and be efficient and just be as accurate
and everything that he has been this
year and really throughout the you know
the time his is his time in an arbor
and yet he delivers every time like he
has been that quarterback who steps up
in those moments and delivers with his
arm or with his legs so I think he's a
first round talent I think a lot of
people probably feel that way around him
I think there's going to be a lot of
quarterbacks who are who are put in that
conversation with pennick with McCarthy
with obviously Caleb Williams and Drake
may you hear a lot of some people might
feel that way about Bo Knicks as well
Jaden Daniels is obviously going to fall
into that conversation I mean there are
a number of quarterbacks that are going
to be looked at and May maybe some of
these teams have potential first round
grades on um or or or maybe you know
second round grades but ended up getting
desperate and seeing them there and
wanting to take them in the first round
yeah I was wondering about that because
if I'm taking you in the top five or top
10 I you're a different quarterback then
I'm taking you at the end of the first
round
right that's fair and I think you've got
like Jaden Daniels with the season that
he had this year who probably next to
penx has the next best film of anyone
you're watching just with his dual
threat ability how much he's improved
from his time at Arizona State to LSU as
a passer and from the pocket another guy
again great guys Authority the league
neighbors will be a first round pick and
wide receiver in my opinion but it
doesn't take away from what he's built
and what he's done and so you know he's
a guy that I think teams might consider
as we continue to watch these these NFL
teams adapt to more uh College style
offenses allowing quarterbacks to be
part of that rushing attack or looking
for a quarterback with Mobility he's
going to start being that conversation
and then you you look at other
intangibles like Bo Knicks set an NCA
record for completion percentage this
year I mean extremely accurate has
continued to improve his ability to play
the position from the pocket but yet you
still see those playmaking ability uh
assets that he's got when he needs to
pull it out it was kind of like he
leaned on it too much at Auburn he goes
to Oregon and he's put together uh quite
the career and I think quite the resume
to show NFL teams that he's more than
just a really good athlete playing
quarterback he's also really accurate
he's a good decision maker and he can
make some plays when you need him to
make some plays so this is a loaded
quarterback draft class in my opinion
you know some people look at like Caleb
Williams Drake man those are like those
top top five talented guys I would say
penck tape and Jaden Daniels tape for us
both those two up into that conversation
as well this year he's Brady Quinn
former college and NFL quarterback
working for Fox their college football
analyst um NFL regular season most
disappointing team was
who probably the Saints um I I just
think that was a team that pre-season
had I think the heaviest odds or
favorite to win the NFC South it was a
loaded roster it was one in which I
really thought you know Derek Carr who
did play much better football down the
stretch was going to be a big time
difference for them I thought they'd be
hosting a playoff game uh this this
upcoming weekend and it wasn't the case
and and at times it just felt like they
couldn't find a rhythm on offense
defensively they they couldn't showcase
what I think their personnel is on paper
and playing up to that standard U they
were probably the the most iess I guess
disappointing in my mind only because of
the expectations that were out there and
you had the worst team in their division
in the Carolina Panthers and you had a
couple other teams in the Bucks
obviously who I think were a pleasant
surprise but they were the the most
surprising I think they odds to win the
division before the season like plus 800
no one really saw that coming um and
then Atlanta obviously just fired Arthur
Smith um you know they they plus some
people might had high expectations I
always thought they they needed you know
a quarterback so the reality is the
saints were probably that team for me
this year even though the record isn't
that bad yeah I said Jacksonville
because I thought they could get to the
AFC title game with that talent but do
you have any hesitation about signing up
Trevor Lawrence longterm if you're
Jacksonville I don't um and I think
there's a lot of things that they need
to check under the
and re-evaluate there whether it's the
inconsistencies and play calling and
whether that's on Doug Peterson or press
Taylor you know only those two really
know behind closed doors it seemed like
Trevor Lawrence was constantly playing
through some sort of injury this year
the Calvin Ridley trade and and you know
all the hype we heard before the season
didn't really work out the way I think a
lot of us had thought it was going to
work out where he would be this Dynamic
player that maybe wins you know comeback
player of the year and I always say that
because at this point I have no idea
what the criteria is for the AP or the
comeback Player of the Year in the NFL
because it seems like it's just it's a
wide net like if you have a really good
season and you didn't play or got hurt
or something else happened last year
there's a decent chance you could be a
comeback player of the year um but but I
digress and their defense I think they'
they've got again some solid pieces but
collectively as a unit outside of when
they were able to generate turnovers
they struggled to get off the field they
struggle to you know stop opponents from
having big plays it just it felt like
this team you know overachieved last
year and we had high expectations this
year and you looked at their schedule
and said they should probably be one of
the top teams in the AFC but it never
really came together the way it needed
to explain CJ
St um I I think
he he inhabits all of the things that
you're looking for in the NFL game from
a quarterback perspective you know the
first thing is he's he's accurate like
that is something that people talk about
accuracy and they'll talk about
mechanics uh I'm personally the biggest
believer in the Improvement and accuracy
comes from your eyes and understanding
where you need to go to the football and
and addressing those throws and
consistently throwing off of a a
consistent base that allows you to be
more consistently accurate he he does
that like he knows where to go with the
football he's extremely accurate when he
gets there and I don't care how you want
to stop the tape but every time when if
you want to stop before he releases the
football he's got a great base a great
platform he finds a way of getting to
that and delivering an absolute strike
and then he's got the ability like we
saw in his final game in college but
also throughout the course of the season
when things aren't there the ability to
scramble by time keep his eyes downfield
but but I think the accuracy is the
first thing and really he's got the ab
to do that all three levels and he's a
passer not a thrower which he can shape
throws you know I always think like when
you watch his pregame warm-up have you
you guys seen it when he's shooting the
basketball and he's swinging the back
he's doing all these different drills
he's got such a good feel for how the
ball's gonna come off his finger and how
it's gonna how it's gonna feel coming
off his hand to be able to shape it into
different types of Windows like you have
to do to achieve the level he's doing
right now and so he's got a unique I
think an uncanny ability to be able to
just kind of feel and play the game uh
utilizing his skill set and then last
thing I think it's just clutch like I
think he loves when the game's on the
line put on him he'll make a throw he'll
make a play to be able to give his team
a chance to go win the football game so
honestly the biggest crime for the
Texans this season is the fact they
don't have tank Dell because I'd love to
see what this team could do now that
they're in the playoffs and and Nico
Collins playing out of his mind and if
tank Dell is a part of this and Noah
Brown back healthy I'd love to see what
this team would be capable of doing yeah
sometimes we overthink the position you
know when we look at quarterbacks we
like oh we got to break down everything
and and you know sometimes you just look
at the tape and I watched that game
against Georgia and I kept coming back
to that like what is the knock on him oh
you know he's not processing at the line
of scrimmage then it feels like there's
there's people out there who are trying
to slander somebody so they go lower or
you get a chance to get that I mean
there's a lot of games that are played
there leading up to the draft as you
know but I I just I kept going back to
the Georgia game I'm going the guy did
everything you would want to it's almost
like DeShawn Watson when he was when he
was playing in college I kept going wait
what is the knock on him like on the
field that dude answered he won a title
and then we kept going n well you know I
think Mitchell tris's got a greater
upside and you're like okay all right
keep overthinking it well you know you
don't know what it is I think in today's
world with all the data and analytics
that we have we now have all this
information and and we want to find a
use for the information and the hardest
thing is when you when you say like put
on the tape it's like we can all put on
the tape and watch the guy and go man
he's really good right or hey he's
really fast well yeah but how fast is he
all right let's go let's go have him run
a 40 yard uh Sprint and then we'll
compare him to everyone else because you
know you do that in a game of football
right you get down in t-shirt and shorts
and a three-point stance and you're
gonna go from a stop and run straight 40
yards it's like well that's that's not
really the best way of comparing but
that's just like what we do to be able
to get an idea of how fast that guy is
so I I think honestly the evaluation
process now more than ever has relied on
finding these data points finding these
ways of measuring guys whether it's
their processing their cognitive their
athleticism and we're looking for a way
of justifying our decision right because
it's tough and and looking at hey it's
probably a variety of things there's a
ton of variables that affect anyone's
performance and what they're capable of
as a player both good and bad but if we
can figure out a way of then justifying
the decision based on these metrics that
that helps us feel better about it right
like if you just go yeah I don't know I
kind of fell I had a gut instinct right
like tonight's game if you if I asked
you to who you who you putting your
money on tonight and you said I don't
know I think Michigan's pretty tough to
be I'm L the four and a half or whatever
the numberers at now what makes you say
that that's my gut like if I if I if I
when you called me and we're talking
right now and I said that to you you'd
be like well I don't I don't want to
follow that I don't feel very good about
that I need a reason I need some data
points or some Analytics to help me be
like yeah that makes sense okay I'll bet
along with you that's where we're at now
and I think that's why we over complica
things is we can't put a metric data
point Etc outside of stats you know from
watching the tape and understanding and
appreciating like what guys are capable
of and so we try to find other ways of
doing that and that's how we make it
complicated more difficult than it needs
to be always great to tr talk to you
Brady thanks for joining us thanks for
having me enjoy the game tonight all
right it's Brady Quinn Fox Sports